ilya first of all big congratulations
you to know each other you both well you
graduated from webster i'm not sure what
your capacity at webster is right now
but you know your opponent aram hakobian
who is still a webster student how did
you approach this game
as as we can see by by the result of the
opening phase i i
i failed greatly
i um i i've mixed up all my home
preparation and actually got into uh
into a slightly uh dubious position that
was opening but yeah i know that aram is
uh is probably uh one of the very few
people who actually works a lot on the
opening phase of the game and uh and i i
wasn't i wasn't really hoping to to get
anything concrete any any advantage
shadows opening i just wanted to get a
playable position in which i miserably
failed to do so as we can see uh yeah at
this point yeah at this point in the
game i think maybe i have slight
pressure just because of the difference
in bishop so my bishop is
pretty active after my next move in 84
it gets out looks like some sort of a
catalan bishop but with the king on the
other side yeah exactly i know he has a
really really funny looking catalan
structure
but yeah it felt like i have a little
bit of something and and i think around
probably didn't think it was enough
because he
he he was a little bit careless and i
think this bishop a form was what what
gave me uh uh something um
something concrete and advantages that
can already uh be working wasn't yeah so
around just kept kept you know
approaching uh really carelessly
carelessly and after roxy five he uh uh
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure how much
better i am after rock c5 but as we
could see from the game the one that
around went for was losing by force
unfortunately and yeah there's really
not much not much to say there uh but
what he might have missed is
yeah if he goes rook d rocky ii is
already a uh yeah as as ancient points
out there's a double question mark
because black cannot avoid losing
material so i suppose black had to uh go
into a defensive and try to defend the
b7 pawn right now which which would
probably
be still okay but once again black got
uh quite a few unnecessary weaknesses
for themselves with their last couple of
moves such as kf6 and e5 yeah i think we
were looking at the rook c8 oh
interesting that's the best way yeah
what happens if we just take the pawn is
zero coming to c2 it actually goes check
oh don't really want to go this way i
thought i saw kc1 actually because then
rook c7 knight c3 and maybe i missed i
missed out on some maybe some draw oh no
no actually bishop d3
bishop g2 and knight a4 but this is not
this is not over is it uh we can also
push up d3 can you go rook d1 there's
king d2 as well this actually this might
just be a draw no knight d5 this was
this oh yeah uh this might be just a
draw of black takes on c3 though which
is kind of upsetting yeah so in the end
king d2 and i take c3 if bc just bishop
c4 this might not be enough to win i i i
su maybe even e4 maybe even e4 and i'm
wondering i wonder who's better
no okay now no way can block be better i
have bishop f1 always so uh that's true
yeah i think i'm still trying to win but
definitely uh your black can can build
some kind of fortress here but even
either way it seems that the
compensation is pretty pretty logical
right but obviously when
so when when you get in a completely
equal position out of the opening you're
not looking to give your opponent any uh
any benefits such as you know material
advantage or positional advantage so
it's understandable why aram was going
was trying to to force things into into
uh and to force draw and unfortunately
blundered
i think what he blundered was so after
knight c3
bishop c2 ak1 rock takes f2 bishop e4 so
over here if you go back one move into
the bishop a4 i thought at first i
myself saw that knight a4
makes a draw which information doesn't
work because knight d5
so now yeah whichever yeah this this
very important check
wins me a piece because yeah my rook
comes down and takes the bishop on c2
yeah
so that's that was a blunder and after
unfortunately there is nothing better
for black than
what aram did i believe which is to go
into this end game down in exchange but
that's that's just a completely losing
end game it's not even just on the
exchange it's also positionally right
yeah it is a lot of open files i have i
have poor majority in the queen side how
all my pieces right there is just
everything just works out for me and
yeah it was really a really
heartbreaking way to lose for a run but
yeah really happens
you are the sole leader at least until
the other games are finished it does
look like sam savion might be converting
uh that game into a full point that's
going to uh have you guys as co-leaders
going into the final game who are you
playing the final i'm playing ray we're
gonna have like a very exciting two
final games because sam is going to be
playing jeffrey as black as well so um
we'll see we're going to be playing ray
as black as well yeah so we both i i
assume we both will try to hold our
ground and let's see what happens
i i hold no pressure i'm already i'm
already way over performing
than what i've what i've kind of
expected myself
to uh to to do in this term and so i
whatever happens i'm happy and by the
way we did get the word that jeffrey won
his game oh okay nice so he's he's one
he's trending exactly so he's he's one
point behind but he still has has a shot
to to join us if he wins his last game
yeah that's nice well ilya a very
exciting round to come we wish you good
luck in that one thank you everyone
thank you alejandra i like the way that
this tournament is finishing up some of
the leaders facing each other